[Música]
yo soy fin obviamente ése no es mi
nombre real y porque no uso mi nombre es
real pues verán soy esa clase de persona
que siempre tapa a la cámara de los
dispositivos las compulsas teléfonos y
eso soy esta clase de personas que
procuran aunque asentarse dando la
espalda una entrada una ventana una
puerta algo así
soy esa clase de persona que cuando va
caminando procura regresar en los pasos
para ver si nadie lo está siguiendo
si quieres ver también más raro soy esa
clase de persona que cambia su chip
telefónico cada mes esta semana hoy en
el chip número 81 ahora en cuenta es
bueno pero por qué hago esto
digo por paranoico y todo esto no pero
por qué y las redes porque me hace
sentir seguro y justo eso es lo que
quiero compartir hoy con ustedes
cómo transformó estas manías estas
paranoias en un sentimiento de seguridad
y para eso les voy a contar una historia
en tres actos spoiler al final darth
vader es el padre klaus
bueno primer actor era 1999 esa época
donde el mundo se iba a acabar porque
las computadoras iban a volverse a lo
que hacen el 2000
britney spears y los bucks y los dos
estaban en lo máximo y el tuviera chivo
salvo sé porque yo tenía 14 15 años y
por cosas de la vida decido salirme de
casa y este y revivir solo no
independizarme y recuerdo que yo estaba
muy feliz cuando di ese paso estaba muy
feliz sentía que era poderoso que no me
podía detener la experiencia de ir en el
metro era así como lo guau no sean nada
me va a detener y recuerdo muy bien que
un día termine en la estación toreó
caminando entre donde están los camiones
y todo está entre paradero y de repente
llega un cuate y así vamos con
picahielos y cito textual llega me dice
que transa carnal al chile porque me lo
tumbó no le juega el payaso caiga se con
el barro y así de
qué está pasando en mi cabeza ahora creo
que tengo un nuevo amigo solo que no
entiendo qué dice ya después me di
cuenta que me estaban asaltando
y esta fue muy curioso porque realmente
me sentí muy mal en ese momento toda
esta alegría que traía todo este ímpetu
esta seguridad se fue en un segundo al
demonio
y pues bueno me sentí seguro me volví un
poquito paranoicos todo eso pero la vida
sigue
yo tenía que
puedes pagar cuentas comer y esas cosas
que hacemos los humanos de vez en cuando
me monté una empresa un negocio que
cambia el mundo bueno la realidad es que
me puse a vender cepillos y cepillos de
masaje si alguien conoce estos cepillos
probablemente sea mi culpa por favor
hashtag no me odien
pero bueno empiezo a vender cepillos de
puerta en puerta tocando de puerta a
puerta y obviamente obviamente me
empieza a meter en cualquier lugar
cualquier colonia cualquier vecindad
abrir las chapas de los edificios para
meterme a vender esa última que no le
digan a nadie este y vendía obviamente
me asaltaron un montón de veces 30 veces
para ser exactos
y cada vez me volvía más y más paranoico
pero algo también algo que también pasó
es que cada vez empezaba a prevenir oa
tratar de entender qué estaba pasando y
tomar acciones para que ya no siguiera
pasando
en esa época ya tenía colaborando
conmigo trabajando conmigo a 67 personas
entonces una de las primeras acciones
que tomé fue que todos teníamos que
salir a vender en equipo
nadie podía ir solo para irnos cuidando
otras secciones que tomé fue comprar un
mapa ya rojo antes de google más
existían papel y pues trazaba un plan de
donde iba a vender cada equipo
esto me servía de dos cosas una que no
estuvieran vendiendo en el mismo lugar
optimizar el territorio y dos que no
estuviera alguien vendiendo en el norte
de la ciudad y otro en el sur y otro por
allá entonces cualquier contingencia
estaban cerca acción número dos siempre
tenían que tener saldo en el celular
cuando los celulares se usaban para
llamar al bueno y esto era porque se
tienen que reportar entre ellos cada
20-30 minutos y si en algún momento
alguien no se contactaba pues ya nos
contábamos todos y veíamos qué hacemos
los llamamos bola
otra de las acciones que ahí es donde
saqué mi manía de estar revisando que
nadie me sigan pues pues que siempre
estuvieron muy atentas
que aprendí con esto que es importante
entender el contexto es importante
aprender leer a leer este contexto y
tomar medidas ante los posibles riesgos
que pueden haber
y eso fue una gran gran lección les
estaba contando que yo ya tenía 67
personas trabajando conmigo lo cual
hacía que yo ya no tuviera que ir a
trabajar en ese entonces me dedicaba
literalmente a los lunes ir a comprar
cepillos todos los días en la mañana y
de entregar cepillos y todos los días a
la tarde ir a recoger plátano
y esto estuvo muy padre porque esto me
permitió a dedicarme a otras cosas no
acabar mi pre para pagar facturas y
sobre todo algo muy importante me
permitió dedicarme a lo que más me
interesaba en ese momento algo
sorprendente algo que era lo mejor que
había en ese momento y era jugar esa
campaña el 2
y justo con esto quiero empezar el acto
número 2 que es como pasa al mundo
digital
jugamos el sofá ayer jugábamos con la
peste que era un español que estaba en
españa jugábamos con arte joven que
estaba en corea jugamos con lancelot que
estaba en la computadora de al lado y
este ya genial era un mundo
interconectado era algo súper nuevo para
mí todo era posible nada me va a detener
estamos en internet uol hasta que de
repente como se abre la charola del city
boom se mueve el sme del mouse y pum la
impresora me empieza a insultar lo juro
imprimí solito sólo para mí
me habían hackeado ok nos habían
hackeado
y ahí relacione el mismo sentimiento que
cuando conocí a un amigo del pequeño nos
en ese mismo sentimiento de que está
pasando no todo es tan hermoso no todo
es tan bello qué pasa a correr y pues
nada resulta que
que el ingeniero el técnico que daba
soporte a todas estas cámaras
todas estas computadoras a este café
internet pues puede ser que nos había
hackeado hackeado no había puesto hay un
troyano y bla bla bla y desde entonces
estas cosas me dan un montón de miedo
esas cosas con su foco verde del mal
desde entonces tapó las cámaras siempre
como todos en esta sala verdad verdad
by bueno empieza a entender cómo
funciona este nuevo mundo y en esta
época el mismo que nos había hackeado me
regaló mi primer libro de programación
me empieza explicando un poco de cómo
funciona internet las tecnologías y todo
este rollo esto me lleva a estudiar y
adentrarme cada vez más y más en el tema
algo que entrega la universidad estudié
ciencias mejor que ciencias
computacionales e incluso me llevó a
viajar dentro del país y fue el país por
ejemplo japón y estudiar a japón y ahí
entra el tercer acto
ya estaba de vacaciones aquí en méxico
cuando de repente tsunami japón terror
y yo pierdo mi vuelo porque cerraron
todos los aeropuertos y eso pierdo en mi
vuelo y no tengo plata para comprar
nuestro vuelo para regresar a estudiar a
japón así que qué hago pues hago lo que
cualquier persona hubiera hecho en esa
época montarse una empresa de startup o
tratar de hacer una empresa ésta no
estaba de moda el emprendedurismo estaba
de moda todo este rollo no
para la ciudad de mexico y empiezo a ir
a un montón de eventos todos los eventos
de tecnología de que vamos a hacer un
estado de que vamos a hacer millonarios
con aplicaciones empiezo serio y un día
sin querer llegó un evento que estaba
desarrollando américa latina
y eso fue bien extraño porque de repente
tenemos un montón de gente talentosa y
oña tratando de resolver problemas
sociales sin que les importara la plata
el dinero no y para mí fue el primero
que raro porque no quieren dinero pero
segundo es genial que estén cambiando el
mundo y estén dedicando hacia temas
sociales empiezo a ir más eventos y
terminó en un evento que se llamaba open
data day y si es así de niños cómo suena
open data d
entonces en este pen de taddei convocan
a periodistas activistas programadores
distintos perfiles diseñadores lo hablan
y empieza a trabajar con grupos de gente
como los periodistas los activistas
defensores de derechos humanos y digo
wow
esta banda hace cosas increíbles yo
quiero hacer eso afortunadamente en este
tipo de eventos pues me jalan y me
vuelvo fellow del proyecto de escuela
datos es color de era y trabajo más de
cerca con estos grupos que les digo con
estas personas y ahí es donde me doy
cuenta a ver momento estas personas se
están metiendo con gobiernos hasta
gobiernos se están metiendo con
corporativos con crimen organizado
y se están poniendo en un riesgo muy muy
alto y entonces es cuando digo haber
momento a lo mejor toda esta paranoia
que yo tengo puede servir para pues
hacer más seguro el trabajo de los
periodistas de los defensores se están
decido
pues dedicarme cien el tema de seguridad
digital para activistas periodistas y
defensores hoy en día
junto con mi equipo estamos formando
nuestra organización a punto de salir y
bueno creo que esta idea de volver la
paranoia en algo de seguridad pues puede
funcionar tanto que mozilla vería el
reloj de mozilla para para continuar con
esta historia
esta es más o menos la historia y pues
quiero que él se tomen un segundo para
relajarnos tantito y quiero que hagamos
un ejercicio por favor todos cierren los
ojos
relájense piense que están aquí
escuchando la mejor charla de todo el
texto
y piensen aquí que están tranquilos sin
ningún prometo si de repente se acuerdan
que dejaron la estufa encendida
o que dejaron la llave del coche pegada
o peor aún dejaron su celular sin
bloquear en la casa de su pareja
bueno pues es que acaban de sentir ese
micro infarto que les acaba de dar es lo
que yo llamo el sentimiento de paranoia
y ese micro infarto se puede transformar
en un sentimiento de seguridad si
tomamos acciones y entendemos contexto
si tomamos hábitos y eso es lo que
quiero compartir con ustedes tomen todo
este sentimiento de paranoia y
conviertan a través de acciones y de
hábitos en un sentimiento de seguridad
ok esta historia va a continuar pero por
ahora es todo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]